if saudis carried out such an
assassination this should be seen as
defiance against turkey and disregard of
law saudi state tv reported that 11
princes three current and dozens of
former ministers have been detained who
murdered him who lured him in there who
chopped him into bits and his body's
never been found it's mbs the crown
prince of saudi arabia and he pays no
price of any kind did it cost you
anything to leave
i will not comment on the content of the
agreement with you in the government
saudi arabia couldn't have struck oil at
a better time it was the 1930s and
america was at the very start of its
massive expansion into the world
superpower and to fuel this growth they
needed oil and a lot of it see oil isn't
just used for fuel it pervades every
part of our lives it fuels our factories
our homes our plastics even our
fertilizer to grow our food so whoever
controls a lot of the world's oil supply
is in a very powerful position
so saudi arabia invited the us over to
build a relationship with them they sold
the u.s 170 thousand dollars worth of
land that would coincidentally turn out
to hold the biggest oil fields on the
planets
the saudi government set up a joint
enterprise between them and the fourth
biggest oil corporations in america and
this joint venture would be called
aramco the drilling begins and the money
starts flowing in
see saudi arabia was smart they knew
they had a lot of leverage thanks to
their oil but they also knew these vast
lands of oil also presented a problem
what was going to stop saudi arabia's
not so friendly neighbors from just
invading and taking over their oil
fields not much they needed security
they needed a big strong brother to
watch over their back
so in 1945 while the u.s desperately
needed oil to support the war it struck
a deal with king abdul aziz oyo in
exchange for security america would
train saudi soldiers and build a
state-of-the-art military base and in
return saudi arabia would sell them as
much oil as they needed this would prove
to be the deal of a lifetime and that's
why today the house assad is the world's
richest royal family allegedly worth
over 1.4 trillion dollars yes you heard
that right trillion that's more than the
gdp of australia spain mexico and even
switzerland in comparison the british
royal family is only worth around 88
billion dollars that means the house
assad is worth 16 british world families
when you think about the most powerful
families in the world you might think of
the rothschilds or the rockefellers or
even the waltons behind walmarts but the
saudi dynasty has slept relatively under
the radar in the west even though
they're perhaps the most powerful
bloodline in the world
every time the saudi royal family ends
up in the news it's scandal after
scandal after corruption allegation but
the saudi dynasty has learned a cold
hard truth with enough money and
assassinations any problem can be solved
if there was a crime and if the
criminals are identified what is
necessary should be done to punish the
perpetrators it's a it's a gruesome
murder that happened outside authorities
uh president biden promised to make the
saudis quote pay the price and make them
the pariah that they are
this is the unimaginable wealth of the
house assad the most powerful bloodline
in the world
[Music]
the house assad managed to make
trillions of dollars because they're an
absolute monarchy a kingdom where they
control all the state-owned enterprises
because of this they always know what to
invest in and what businesses to start
from the most profits unfortunately we
don't have that level of influence or
insights but what if you did that is
where trends comes in trends is one of
the most valuable knowledge hubs on the
internet for aspiring entrepreneurs by
helping you find the next business idea
before it explodes onto the world stage
here's how it works you sign up for
trends using the link below and every
month trends will send you new and
emerging business trends that are still
flying under the radar saving you tons
of research and money on testing new
business plans trends even has live
training sessions with industry experts
so you can learn all the skills you need
to succeed like how to fundraise the
best seo practices and much more and if
you can't make it to the live you'll
have all these resources waiting for you
in their past training library and one
of my favorite trends features is their
databases which gives you a ton of
useful info like the fundraising data
for thousands of past kickstarter
campaigns and the trends recession
database so you can learn how businesses
made it through some of the toughest
economic times in history to take
advantage of everything trends has to
offer all you have to do is go to
trends.comtran and you'll get a seven
day trial of transfer just one dollar
that's trends.class jake trying to start
your one dollar seven day trial thanks
to trents for sponsoring this video
[Music]
after that sweetheart deal with the us
in 1945 the house assad and the u.s
worked together in peace as the us rose
to power over the decades so did the
house assad everything was working out
perfectly until america got involved
with israel in 1973 the arab israeli war
pitted most of the arabic countries
against israel who was trying to take
over palestinian land america felt they
should side with israel and this
understandably made the entire middle
east pretty angry as punishment the
biggest oil producing countries in the
arabic world who were a part of an
organization called opec decided it was
time to teach the us a lesson the saudi
king tells a ramco to stop drilling and
suddenly america was based on an oil
shortage unlike anything it had ever
seen
the odd even system can't do anything
about the problem of no gas some of the
people online here
have been in other lines and still don't
have a tank of gas to emphasize if you
cut off an empire's fuel they will
literally collapse in a matter of months
and that was the position america was in
so the american empire had to strike
another deal with the king of oil saudi
arabia if saudi promised to sell oil in
only us dollars which america could
print out thin air america will give
saudi arabia weapons military training
political support basically whatever the
saudi king slash dictator wants america
will support it or at least turn a blind
eye all in the name of securing
america's lifeblood the two powers agree
and the petrol dollar is born where oil
the fuel of the world is only sold in
dollars giving america a huge advantage
against all other empires because
america could print dollars out of than
error basically giving them free oil and
in exchange saudi arabia got the
protection it desperately needed what
formed out of this agreement was an
almost unbreakable alliance between the
us and saudi arabia that still last to
this day now saudi arabia was faced with
another problem it had more than enough
oil to supply the world but now they
have way too much money in 1980 saudi
only had a population of 9 million
people and it was making billions in
profits the royal family pocketed as
much as they could they reinvested money
into america boosting the us economy
even more and they also bought out a
ramco meaning that the house assad
completely took over oil production in
the country and rebranded the company as
saudi aramco the royal family now had a
monopoly on all oil production and sales
in the country and they became even more
insanely rich than they ever wore before
and it only went up from there but with
more money came a lot more
responsibility something that the house
assad didn't really want to deal with
[Music]
the bin ladens and assads were great
friends and no i'm not kidding the bin
laden family owned one of saudi arabia's
biggest construction businesses and they
worked closely with the sauce to build
up saudi arabia cities and it was under
saudi world orders that osama decided to
cross over to afghanistan to fight
against the soviets america asked the
king to help with their fight against
communism so the king sent his best men
which included osama when osama got back
from afghanistan freshly radicalized
with his very own unit of trigger happy
soldiers he hated the fact that america
was using saudi the islamic world's
holiest country as a military playground
and he wanted them out obviously the
house assad couldn't just kick their
american friends out and lose all that
money so they attempted a delicate
balancing act between keeping the u.s
happy while not losing their best
construction company but that wasn't
enough for osama as we all know and he
turned his hatred on the u.s but here's
the thing even after america identified
the mastermind behind 911 and how 15 of
the 19 men involved were saudi the royal
family refused to accept or acknowledge
that their people were involved america
was worth trillions of dollars to saudi
arabia but without the popular support
of its muslim citizens the house assad
wouldn't have a country to run so they
played their balancing act again trying
to keep america happy with its
investigations and punishments it dealt
while not losing the support of the
people who kept them in power america
invades practically every other middle
eastern country besides the one the
majority of the men were from saudi
arabia and today nothing has really
changed
[Music]
saudi arabia is the world's biggest
weapon buyer and most of those arms come
from the us america would buy oil in
dollars and the house assad would use
those same dollars to buy weapons it was
the perfect trade but then came 911.
everyone thought with osama being saudi
arabian and so many saudis being
involved in the attack that the us was
stopped selling to them but that never
happened in 2020 saudi arabia spent over
46 billion dollars on its military
practically all of that around 88 went
to the us losing such a great customer
wasn't an option so the house assad and
the u.s struck another deal as long as
it looked like saudi was going after the
terrorists america can keep supplying
the weapons after all saudi arabia is
such an important country when it comes
to keeping the peace in the middle east
so america boosted its weapons sales to
the house assad and unsurprisingly a lot
of those weapons end up in the same
hands of the terrorists america is
fighting against and when those weapons
aren't sold to america's enemies they're
used to fuel saudi arabia's endless wars
like the one in yemen it's been going on
for over six years and has caused
millions of deaths due to starvation or
illness
even after saudi crown prince ben salman
ordered a journalist jamal khashoggi to
be assassinated in turkey the us didn't
baton die before he was killed jamal
khashoggi had started openly speaking
out against saudi arabia's involvement
in yemen that proved to be too much of
an embarrassment and the house assad
made sure he disappeared and all the
saudi arabian suspects involved in his
murder they were all arrested or jailed
in luxury villas in riyadh the u.s
government didn't say a word but it's
not just outsiders that feel the wrath
of the house aside when they overstep
with over 15 000 family members the
fighting within the bloodline is just as
ruthless
[Music]
you see for decades society throne was
passed from brother to brother not
father to son so when king salman
announced in 2017 that his son not his
brother would become the next king of
saudi arabia the family was livid how
could the king abandon hundreds of years
of tradition and who did the new crown
prince mohammed bin salman think he was
they were just going to stand by and
watch the entire house assad be
restructured or that's what they thought
mohammed ben salman despite being 31
years old was a ruthless strategist and
he knew just what to do with all his
dissenting cousins he purged them he
arrested more than 500 of his most
powerful family members princes
businessmen princesses ministers he
cleared out the ritz hotel in riyadh and
kept them under house arrest there for
months why because of corruption
according to ben salman these 500 royals
were quotes weaklings who followed their
own interests rather than public
interests who attacked public money
without regard for religion conscious
morals or patriotism end quotes he was
arresting them for the good of the
kingdom consolidating his power getting
rid of adversaries and seizing his
cousin's assets were just an added bonus
two thousand bank accounts were frozen
and up to 800 billion dollars in cash
and assets were targeted for seizure no
one has dared to challenge the rule of
muhammad bin salman ever since and now
he was free to enjoy life as the head of
the richest bloodline in the world
[Music]
back in july 2015 muhammad bin salman or
mbs arranged a private party to end all
private parties he rented out an entire
maldives resort for a month which cost
him 50 million dollars then he brought
in 150 women celebs like pitbull
jennifer lopez shakira and afro-jack all
to perform and entertain his couple
dozen male friends the alcohol flow the
saudis partied and at one point nbs even
chased the dj offstage so he could try
out the turntables it was everything you
could expect from a middle eastern
billionaire and more until news of the
party leaked to the press almost
immediately the saudis left the women
were taken back to where they came from
and mbs reappeared in his home country
dressed in his traditional clothing and
shaking his head at the people who
thought so little of religion and
morality then he became crown prince and
he toned down his level of concern over
what people thought of him his recent
spending sprees included a 450 million
dollar painting da vinci salvatore mundi
a 300 million chateau in france which
was called the world's most expensive
home and a brand new half a billion
dollar super yachts here mbs was doing
the exact same thing he arrested his own
family for and when he was asked why he
felt so comfortable spending billions
while his people protested against their
wages and economic situation his answer
was simple quo i'm a rich person and not
a poor person i'm not gandhi or mandela
i'm a member of a ruling family that has
existed for hundreds of years before the
founding of saudi arabia end quotes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you